all right so this is a princess potluck
and it's it's fun just to serve a a okay
well first of all like time travels
which is really weird it's what happens
when during beemo noir Jake's got the
bull's eye as face to the eyelashes and
Finn's still doesn't have his shoe
so no sock that's right he's building a
nasty callus and turns out salt to be
part of this princess potluck which I
thought was actually gonna be a
character like you know it's not like
just everyone brought part of the
princess to assemble her and then eat
her later so I don't know um but no it's
just a potluck where a lot of princesses
come including a new Princess the bouncy
room princess was a messy house bouncy
houses
yes takes all my body so that was very
funny and yeah but the Ice King finds
out he wasn't invited though technically
he why's he just doesn't check his mail
Ice King and he goes in and he tries to
you know sabotage and stop a sense
günther in as a princess but he blends
in fine and he tries to do his own party
but it's not as good and he's like oh
yeah I'm the Ice King and he tries to
destroy everything
I think finds like he was invited and
then he tries to have fun and Finn wins
the raffle prize which was a what what
was it again something lard slug large
look like is that something like that
and this arrow keeps trying to fit hit
Jake because looks like he has this big
bullseye and at the very end it's a
character that I know I see before
because brie went up and I don't
remember that character so I apologize
don't you remember the squirrel that's
pissed off at Jake because Jake never
responds to any of his questions
probably Champa so I kind of like it's
the initially it came from the peanut
other Duke of nuts yes okay yeah I'm
throws the letter to Jake well Jake's
sitting on the log and it floats and
just sits there and he never reads it or
anything like that okay now I do
remember that now yeah man you need a
well we have to like it was a 1:21 is
that what we - yeah I mean it's like
it's it's a lot to remember for these
little you know eleven minute you know
they throw so much at you uh before that
that was my favorite running joke is
when he says you look like a bull's-eye
and just this arrow keeps trying to hit
him you don't know where it's coming
from
um but uh it's totally fine I mean it's
a it's sort of a nice return to form for
the Ice King just another very goofy
episode of him just trying to be popular
and feel needed and stuff and taking it
too far and everyone acts their goofy
silly selves and you know there's a
couple funny lines and uh hey I can't
forget too much else to say I mean it's
just it's it's fine it's funny it's
serviceable oh it was it was bright and
colorful and you know yeah but another
glitch is a glitch yes um I liked it the
only part I did not like because again
it dragged what's the phone call calling
the banana guards like it was funny
because once he started doing the old
lady voice and it cut back and
everything needed costumes um that was
funny but then it just kind of went on a
bit too long and I was like kind of done
it it works for me though I know what
you're talking about it's like you know
come on we get the joke but for me it's
it was just enough for me to say how far
can he keep going with this with it
being so unnecessary yeah the funny is
what I think I've ever seen of that was
there was a Simpsons episode where I
think he's trying to get a loan up bank
or somebody it's like any no no I and
latest Simpsons especially enough fan of
but this one really made me laugh where
he's like I think he needs his wife to
co-sign eyes like oh she's just behind
that borscht let me go to her and he
goes behind there he's just like you
know honey will you sign this loan for
me yes I sure well oh you're so great
Auggie yes sir yeah and then like he
just gets down as knees a just goes
daddy ask the man for some candy
oh all right little what it's like there
was no reason for him to do this little
kid uh you know even though the guy fell
for any ways funnier when you decide
it's it it was pretty funny before I got
unfunny with me telling it but
could go on going through but really had
nothing I was really expecting this to
still be laughter over what I said but
that really backfired so why don't you
um you can go then I think you killed it
I think it did
well momentum on this one The Simpsons
both started this great thing of comedy
and then killed it no no you killed it
it's like and yeah after it was dead you
kicked it a few times and probably
spitting it's I like that Ice King joke
you were talking about with the phone
yeah okay anything else so long that
Ranma not funny in this episode
no the episode was fine then like the
Simpsons that they really should have
thrown the towel if they had me as PR
guy they would be fun here because this
you can tell that joke I just did there
I Love You Man but don't touch me